hey we've we got a voicemail this
morning that I don't really understand
and I want to get your help in
interpreting our voicemail number of
course is two one nine two david p what
do you think this voicemail caller is
talking about take a listen yes I gave
her this is Jamie probably the message
and there's a pause right now however my
concern is the Bernie Sanders thing if
it's a distraction
all right I don't get it is the Bernie
Sanders thing a distraction
what is the Bernie Sanders thing is it
like a huge you mean that he's running
for president or what it would it be a
distraction from like I genuinely don't
understand what this caller is
suggesting is the implication that
Bernie has no shot
and therefore running is the distraction
or does he mean that media coverage some
particular stuff I have no idea what
this person is asking about is the
Bernie Sanders thing just the
distraction I don't know what you mean
but if anybody in the audience can help
me interpret it I would very much
appreciate it on the bonus show today we
will talk about a Los Angeles executive
who got their son into USC as a fake
water polo player has been sentenced to
four months in prison is that a fair
sentence we will discuss we will also
talk about a European Court saying that
the right to be forgotten only applies
to web sites inside the European Union
which is a really important ruling
because up until now there was the
presumption that if you are living in
the European Union but you are accessing
websites like Google for example or
another
us-based website that the right to be
forgotten still applies and this
decision suggests that it does not and
Turkish leader Yohan says that nuclear
power should be either free for
everybody or banned altogether we will
talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show two ways to get
instant access to the bonus show
member by signing up at join pakman.com
very quick very easy or become a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
I'll see you then or on tomorrow's show